c'est un dessin animé super connu c'est
le titre le réalisateur est génial c'est
en tout cas ça parle d'une histoire de
poisson pour la bleue et à d'autres
poissons bien sûr c'est pas que les
poissons bleus yann acquis à rien et
d'ailleurs qui s'appelle riz comment il
s'appelle déjà
je suis sur le bout de la langue son nom
revient pas là tout de suite mais il est
plus beau jeu
voilà c'est son père donc où son frère
notamment et non jeu c'est son père
c'est un film sur la mythique we
important c'était quoi
si seulement reprendre mais toi la
girouette aussi sauvé bonjour je
m'appelle de risque donc de quoi comme
le dit moi je suis pas mal et on mise en
quarantaine au nom il me reste combien
de temps à vivre
il faut que j'étais les parents à
l'arête aux courbes ou au non c'est pas
mon choix
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est très
mauvaise nouvelle c'est une étiquette de
transport pour les poissons qu'on aucune
chance à l'institut on les transfère
dans un lieu de vie définitif un
aquarium
ce sont les lions de mer de dangereux
prédateurs ils peuvent rebondir
commences ton pote souci elle va sortir
l'an vous avez aucun souci à vous faire
[Musique]
c'est un truc que ballard je suis
vraiment malade il court encore des
vieux que ça envoie des copeaux accroche
noir mais si tu veux gerber soit sympa
installe toi plutôt à l'arrière penche
toi slb telle loi partez à la recherche
de mes parents au diadème de la tontine
vous l'avez de mauroy en qualité par an
et tu te rappelles comment il n'ya pas
longtemps femme et moi mes revenus alors
je suis pas très sûr mais quelque chose
me dit que doivent être plutôt bleu avec
une pointe de janvier des chances
puis je suis sûr que je les
reconnaîtrais d'éclairer l'air de
famille moi je dis que la traversée de
l'océan c'est le genre de croisière qui
ne pas avoir fait une fois l'an à vue
une seule les copains prochaine sortie
la peine de vous
yannick
l'âge venant je d'ohrid s'est pas perdue
ou les a tués pour la dernière fois j'ai
mais tu sais tu as des petits problèmes
de mémoire
oui on a un petit peu plus de courage
dans le 2 là un petit peu plus
d'expérience dans le 2 mai il est
toujours aussi un peu trop prudent
toujours mais toi la girouette
s'ils savaient bonjour je m'appelle des
risques c'est donc le pool fugueurs donc
il sans arrêt en train de se barrer pour
essayer de trouver une sortie
c'est vraiment un super personnage parce
qu'au début des râleurs il tape veulent
un peu lâche et petit à petit on
découvre que c'est un vrai héros paris
oui riz destiné c'est un requin baleine
si la tache bleue qui parle vous pouvez
peut-être m'aider je cherche mes parents
ont cherché vos parents alors est
complètement myope ce qui est très bien
parce que moi aussi c'est très très dur
à faire leçon baleine mais moi quand je
le fais par moments ça fait bizarrement
ça fait suisse ça vous ennuie raid
parler moins fort
j'ai mal à la tête mon personnage
s'appelle baylet
je leur ai dit que je sais que tu parle
de moi dessinée roi qu'il peut plus
servir de son sonar mais j'ai entendu
les médecins disent que je suis là ce
mélange entend absolument tout ce que tu
dis sur moi on a essayé d'en faire un
vrai personnage pour la france
marc encore vraiment drôle chaque fois
qu'il ouvre la bouche on rit à chaque
fois qu'ils qui se réalise on se réalise
avec lui et ça c'est cool c'est très
drôle c'est extrêmement bien fait rire
tout est poussé réalisme tellement fort
que forcément on y croit et que
forcément rentrer dans l'histoire
ces haltes ans est monté à une vitesse
cc on veut savoir ce qui se passe après
rendez vous le 22 juin dans les salles a
très vite
[Musique]
salut les amis et bienvenue sur le
doublage de le monde de dori le nouveau
film événement disney pixar où j'ai la
chance de prêter ma voix aux dauphins
bélugas du nom de bébé je vous
présentais un petit peu l'équipe c'est
parti alors vous avez ici bas il est un
qui s'occupe de tout ce qui est
projection d'image salut bel et bien tu
t'occupes de quoi toi et moi je
m'occupais de tout ce qui est gestion et
autonome elle 614 quand même mon film en
voilà merci daury nemo est ce que tu as
un petit mot pour notre téléspectateurs
merci nemo voili voilou les copains bon
ben voilà c'est l'équipe du film le
monde de dori et on sera tous en salle
retrouvez-nous le 22 juin pays sap
[Musique]
qui a entendu quoi que j'ai entendu
quelqu'un dire et où ça grouille de
poisson par ici n'importe quel poisson
ouvertes libres justes là là ou là à là
bonjour m'appelle tories ou santé par an
bonjour j'ai perdu ma femme ou les as tu
vu pour la dernière fois j'ai oublié je
cherchais quelque chose j'ai d'accord je
comprends vous avez rendez-vous jeu des
troubles de la mémoire immédiate
cette famille enfin je crois mission
nous tuer leurs télés radios regarde toi
ça elle a été enlevé on a dû l'emmener
dans ce procès même parce que c'est un
hôpital pour les poissons
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est donc c'est pas si simple vous
êtes coincés ici je cherche mes paroles
comme c'est triste je tâche pas super g
il est à l'intérieur les semaines on va
avoir besoin de tortionnaires du
ridicule série atteindra maman est là
qui vont choisir de au hasard et surtout
si je dis ça pour rire
quand ils font chute comme ça qu'ils ont
sûrement leur faire des choses comme une
espèce de géants des camps et les normes
des tentacules et on faisait pas évident
et aussi précises mais pourquoi pas oui
quelque part j'ai une femme je me
retrouverai jamais tout ce qu'un bon
doré accroche noir non j'ai pas envie
qu'on me touche
désolé tout peut arriver à tout le monde
et pas avant
lui fait confiance nous approchions
s'appelait qui toi elle a la tête dans
saint-gobain
adroit devant toi maman papa veut dire
qu'on va bientôt se séparer
maintenant vu comment j'ai pu croire que
je n'es rien tu vas bientôt retrouver
tes parents à l'époque tu les auras
retrouver
ce sera chez moi
ce sont les lions de mer de dangereux
prédateurs ils peuvent rebondir postes
d'emploi dessous si elle va sortir dans
vous avez aucun souci à vous faire
[Musique]
qu'ils s'appellent les troupes de
mémoire immédiate c'est exactement ce
que tu dois dit bon alors on fait comme
si on était les autres courts sa
léthargie salut je veux jouer à cache
cache avec nous oui j'ai rejoint
qu'est-ce qu'ils soient de bons jusqu'à
10 et nous pendant ce temps là on veut
se cacher bah non papa moi je suis le
gentil copains qui veut jouer avec toi
d'accord et ak non aller contre jusqu'à
[Musique]
dans nuirait de parler moins fort j'ai
mal à la tête qui s simon france un pays
là il est arrivé qu'une blessure je sais
que tu parle de moi j'espère qu'il peut
plus servir de son sonar mais j'ai
entendu les médecins disent absolument
tout ce que tu dis sur moi c'est quoi un
sonar normalement la tête de bellême et
des ultrasons et l'écholocalisation lui
permet de repérer des objets à distance
mais apparemment monsieur n'est pas
encore guéri ok donc là c'est sûr tu
parles demain je réellement perdu
d'écholocalisation vue c'est toujours la
main à ma décision je me suis violemment
cognée la tête parce que ça se paie une
bosse peut-être c'est tout à fait normal
pour un béluga d'avoir une grosse tête
c'est le grand jour
nous partons observer la migration des
rêves niveleuse la migration des rêves
nîmes avait maigri ça consiste à rentrer
à la maison
autrement dit d'où l'on vient et comment
ils savent où il faut qu'ils aillent
l'instinct quelque chose qu'on a au fond
de soi un sentiment de familiarité
auquel on ne peut pas résister ma mère
mon père nous t'oublierons jamais daury
mais si j'oublie ma famille m'a menti
vous savez déjà ressenti ça oui
un truc de malade mais là c'était
vraiment avec combat nadia vous pouvez
m'aider
pardon je sais pas nager je trouve que
vous nagez très bien à petit beaucoup
mais pas de grosse souris oui oui oui on
était copine non c'était trop marrant
mais je te raconter une histoire est at
il oublié complètement comme ça pouvait
raconter autant que je voulais je
cherche ma femme mais tu es folle c'est
trop dangereux
ces pauvres
désolé faut que je cligne des yeux
comment vous faites pour les garder
ouverts si longtemps
pas faux 3 bonjour vous pouvez m'aider
[Musique]
c'est l'autre